ils disent vouloir rester ici on les
villages et les bourgs situés loin des
services et les grandes infrastructures
publiques les enfants même une forme de
fierté comme deux d'entre eux me lancer
à la cantonade
ici c'est la corse sans la mer
[Musique]
qui a toute une partie de la population
française qui vit dans des zones rurales
qui peuvent être éloignés des grands
centres de décisions peuvent connaître
des difficultés économiques mais qui
néanmoins est sont très attachés à cette
territoire et au style de vie qui peut y
être associée c'est un livre de
sociologie qui nous plonge dans le
quotidien des jeunes qui habitent dans
ce que j'appelle les campagnes en déclin
donc en déclin démographique qui perdent
des habitants et aussi en déclin
économique puisque les emplois sont de
plus en plus rares et où on essaye en
fait de se mettre à leur place de leur
point de vue j'analyse en fait tout ce
qui compose leur préoccupation quant à
la fois à trouver un travail et le
garder trouver une compagne et la garde
et s'installer finalement dans la visite
adultes le déclic de l'écriture j'ai
envie de dire que c'est déjà une
opposition finalement aux
représentations dominantes de ces
territoires ruraux c'est à dire qu'ils
sont souvent décrits sous l'angle du
négatif par rapport à la ville ont
conclu que la disparition des commerces
des services publics et des grandes
entreprises industrielles aurait amené
un repli sur soi et un individualisme et
moi ce que j'ai constaté par mon enquête
c'est dès que les jeunes ouvriers
employés les adultes des prochaines
générations rural recomposant fait du
collectif
[Musique]
la source d'inspiration elle a été tout
simplement les des amis d'enfance les
personnes de mon entourage est aussi ma
propre vie personnelle pour me rendre
compte qu'il y avait vraiment un
décalage entre ce que nos oeuvres vous à
nous proposer et la vie réelle de ces
jeunes adultes la manière finalement
d'appréhender la ruralité dans son
ensemble aujourd'hui en france est
d'emblée un regard qui nous amène à
homogénéiser des territoires qui sont
très différents entre eux et surtout
aussi j'aimerais qu'on retienne que le
référent urbain ne peut en fait
s'imposer partout et ne convient pas à
tout le monde
[Musique]